aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
créatrice d'avenir un concours pour
accompagner les femmes chefs
d'entreprise et les récompenser et pour
en parler aujourd'hui Sophie fourmeau
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
ambassadrice de cette édition 2023
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler un
peu plus de ce concours oui tout à fait
le concours créatrice d'avenir est dédié
aux femmes qui ont soit créé une
entreprise soit qui en reprennent une ou
soit qui sont associé mais qui ont plus
de 50 % de part dans l'entreprise il
faut que l'entreprise soit domiciliée en
î de France et c'est un concours qui
récompense l'ambition et une vision
entrepreneuriale après il faut concourir
dans l'une des cinq catégorie du
concours innovation quartier
savoir-faire il y a également le prix
public et après il y a le prix vraiment
SOMUM qui est le prix créatrice d'avenir
quelque chose de phare aussi dans ce
concours c'est le prêdonneur est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer un peu en
quoi ça consiste oui tout à fait donc
c'est en fait pour chaque catégorie donc
il y en a C il y a une dotation de 4 00
€ pour chaque gagnante et suite à cela
on peut bénéficier du prêdonneur par
initiative donc le prêtdonneur en fait
c'est un prêt qui est personnel que l'on
contracte avec un prêtdne avec un prêt
bancaire pour le développement la
création et la reprise entreprise et ça
va de paire et c'est un concours qui a
quand même du succès aujourd'hui combien
combien de candidatures est-ce que vous
enregistrez à date aujourd'hui alors
dans les evelines il me semble qu'on est
à 50 un peu plus de 50 dossiers envoyés
réceptionnés alors on va aussi revenir
sur votre parcours parce que vous êtes
aussi une ancienne participante de ce
concours vous avez justement développé
un atelier de rénovation
d'abajour quel a été votre déclic pour
vous inscrire à ce concours en 2020
alors en 2020 je voulais m'inscrire pour
pouvoir développer mon entreprise parce
que j'étais dans une taille critique où
il me fallait vraiment un coup de boost
aussi bien en terme de presse de
visibilité et puis aussi financier et ce
concours créatrice d'avenir m'a permis
d'avoir les deux et qu'est-ce que ça
vous a concrètement qu'est-ce que ça
vous a apporté en terme de chiffre
d'affaires de visibilité alors j'ai eu
beaucoup de retombées médiatiques j'ai
eu un avant après en terme de clientèle
et de chiffre d'affaires ça a
pratiquement doublé quand même mon
chiffre d'affaires il y a une fierté de
la part de mes clients déjà existants et
j'ai eu des nouveaux clients qui sont
venus grâce à la notoriété que j'ai eu
dans la presse et ensuite ça a suscité
également des vocations j'ai pu engager
des apprentis et j'ai pu également
embaucher alors grâce à ce statut
aujourd'hui vous pouvez aussi inspirer
est-ce que c'est important pour vous
d'avoir ce cette influence sur les
femmes qui souhaitent entreprendre
aujourd'hui oui c'est assez important
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de freins que
nous les femmes nous pouvons nous mettre
et ça permet aussi de on va dire
démocratiser l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin donc oui c'est je trouve que
c'est très important de de transmettre
en fait cette expérience et aussi de
dire bah c'est oui c'est peut-être
difficile mais c'est faisable les femmes
elles ont estce que les femmes elles ont
encore peur aujourd'hui de se lancer oui
pour la plupart oui il y a quand même
des freins qu'elles se mettent soit
parce que c'est pas la bonne période
dans leur vie soit parce qu'ell
priorisent leur vie personnelle et elles
se disent non c'est pas le moment alors
que c'est peut-être le moment pour elle
et et et également elles se mettent
plein de frein notamment financier où
elles ont peur un manque de confiance
aussi en elle ça peut être ça bien merci
Sophie fourmeau d'avoir accepté notre
interview si vous aussi vous souhaitez
participer vous avez jusqu'au 30
septembre pour envoyer vos candidatures
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivi tout au long de cette
édition et je vous souhaite de passer
une excellente soirée sur tv78